wow sich krass wie viel frau greco sind
oder kommentare allgemein zum
minarettbau aus dem stadtpark aus der
anscheinend größte offene drogenszene in
der schweiz mega cool das ist außer
diskussion geht vor der kommentator ist
doch mal eine beantwortung besprechen
natürlich seid also diese reporter
behandelt die menschen in diesem park
aber auch wie tiere im zoo war für mich
etwas befremdlich oder auch lieblich
also hannover wo wir genau nicht das
machen genau mit einfach anna und wieso
alfred drucker sondern wirklich mit der
luxe räder vorsichtig der nato und nicht
einfach befehlen wo überhaupt kein bock
hätte zum film zweiter und das schreiben
auch schwierig sie will
schlussendlich an die den nächsten tag
verstanden keine filme will sich
natürlich niemand direkt weil der film
als exit buch zum vertrauen hofbauer
damit im amerika wenn nicht der richtige
moment somit eher bei dem film oder wenn
sie ins licht abgelenkt blickte droge
zum beispiel und dass sie am mini
motivation hinter der sachverstand dass
sie nicht wegen der bis sensationelles
oder risiko machen sondern dass sie ihn
will der umgehen können für zelluläre
perspektiven au und dass das ist die weg
sie next manuelles signal
sie kommentiert office wo mega viel
kommentiert hält das erinnert mich so
sehr an den zürcher platzspitz sind
inzwischen mehr als 30 jahre vergangen
nur kann man nicht wirklich mit dem
spitz und lettern vergleichen
absolut das ist schon jetzt ziel sieg
wären wir das argument wacher und zeige
was jetzt im 20 21 im stadtgarten
kulozik man kann es wirklich verglichen
mit dem man mit dem letter oder
platzspitz das sind zwei paar schuhe
andere jahrzehnt andere droge aber fokus
auf das hier und da sitzt im stadtgarten
fresh punkt 81 zeit kommentiert sehr
interessante dokumente bis mitte
vorteile jetzt thema finanzierung von
konsum noch interessant gefunden
aber das ist auch ein thema wo man noch
hätte können aufgriffe das mit der
finanzierung hans kopitz und folgt im
stadtpark und die meiste zeit ja es wird
cloud es wird auf viele bettler den cool
das beantwortet hoffentlich frau margot
fragt wie bestimmtes thema statt barcoo
respektiv was ist aus sieht man doch
ständig drüber machen
also ich wohne ja da gerade paar minuten
weg und das ist in graubünden letzten
jahren sehr oft die medici und deshalb
ist sexy und mads christensen egal
und irgendwann ist dass wieder richtige
zeitpunkt gekommen ist im new yorker was
ich den namen osama lattek sieht weil
das macht ja nicht sinn zumal fachte
team schnell stand alles hat wilma und
dann wieder gar zum beispiel weil die
bäume bedienen stand abonnenten fasste
die geschichte der den es irgendwelche
leute denen sind das ideale medium soft
hat politischem level besprochen oder
was politiker findet man müsse mache was
ich schon was nicht und die motivation
sitzung malaga was leute die eigentlich
sagen
morbus gitarre fragt was hemmt die
begegnung in der ausgelöst es immer noch
mulmiges gefühl wenn ein park zu viel
aus nein also ihren sich viel weniger
vorurteil will jetzt hat lud kenner und
zum beispiel anstich ich nehme immer
wieder weiß dass die liegt grundsätzlich
friedlich sind vor allem mit wo der
innen können sporadisch wc und was ich
habe mir gefiel kleintieren vorher noch
nie so base in echt gesehen so tiefer
und ja das erbe abhängigkeit das ist ein
fakt ist wurden sascha blätter und der
munition sondern das ist wirklich r
krankheit wo douglas ist und wo wirklich
beeindruckt uns hätten mehr perspektive
geißler und wenn jetzt diese geschichte
bürger ja
einfach mehr kontext zu der ganzen
geschichte
apropos weggelaufen viele fragen auf und
gotcha molina und ja ich bin letzte in
keferloh am mittag und denkt was
versetzt das machen wir das einfach ja
von der merkel vorher das ganze gemacht
absolut to back to back folgt ist denn
schon ein konsum in planung in chur
also es ist es so ein konsumboom kasten
von torhüter morgen hersteller das muss
bezahlt machen muss wissen wie er mache
und es ist ein politischer prozess
einsetzbar bucht bis politiker wirklich
jack taylor okay die möglichmacher säge
das regierung oder auto große dort also
parlament und jetzt ist das langsam ins
rollen chor nichts gefühlt also man ist
immer wieder interviews wo wir sagen ja
mit mir sind da aber dass er die ganze
serie hat der regierungsrat mahlzeit im
interview und nach mallorca
ok frog von alec mono zur polizei wie
würdest du das telefonat mit der polizei
anordnen schauen sie absichtlich weg
bist du bei den dreharbeiten im park
auch manchmal der polizei begegnet
neben ihm begegnet obwohl der
polizeiposten vor der stadtpolizei in
cool
nur 50 meter luftlinie vom stadtpark
entfernt ist im stadtpark an das thema
besprochen mit etwa tempo am lettisch
und denkt meint es der toner viel
brutaler sie und viele halter und
mögliche aber das hätten wir unbedingt
braucht und ich glaube das weiß polizei
da und sie macht deshalb auch nicht
unbedingt mega razzia die ganze genau
weiß das ist irgendwie nicht lässig vom
problem was polizei telefon seit ich sie
machen die show ab und zu apps und aber
nicht zu aggressiv und sie sehr genau
die bibel zum prävention und sogar von
einem high demand and aber weiß nicht
vielleicht hätte man es anders erwartet
viel zeit fragt wie funktioniert das mit
einer wohl nicht von günter sind
fahrende jeden tag der dana oder heinz
zimmer
also handelt in dem stadtpark bottroper
mit dem zürcher dialekt mit dem
italienischen akzent mit schweizer
akzent aus der teile traf in der regel
aber die meisten wohnen aber zu wenig
das mit kriegt also nicht jeder führte
recht fragt also glaube nicht dass da
zum stadtpark pen lite wird verschenkt
wie komische vorstellung dts hätten den
kommentar zu der für pixeliger man sieht
recht wenig in der reportage alles so
pixels und so weiter da kann ich auch
gleich die wand anschauen und ein
hörbuch anschalten ja kein cheftrainer
und der apple logo oder lose möglichst
mega wichtig sie dass die leute sich
wohl fühlen wenn sie mit mir reden und
das ist sie nicht irgendwie zu zwingen
es ist ein heikles thema zum fotokamera
und verstand jeder was seine neigung ist
aber lieber verpixelt und dann habe der
wunsch die abmachung logische wies
respektiert musik und sexseiten cool
gibt es wie in jeder größeren stadt oder
kantonshauptstadt ein heroin programm
richtig aber im stadtpark wird vor allem
based also willst vor allem kokain
konsumiert und das kokain programmen
gibt es ja und dann hetzt mega lessing
gekommen also wird im basketball oder
fußball doku macher beschäftigt ist noch
woanders napster to the brave jetzt gab
es keinen weniger ängstlichen reporter
des riesenreiches zehner wieso motor ist
und ich liebe glanz und gloria haut
danke all guest für die mega ähnliche
kommentar und als audi aber auch alle
anderen dafür positive kommen tag für
konstruktive aber wenn es um zu gott und
reportage selber also sehr gefreut wie
jetzt ohne scheiß 20 cent und nun die
knie ganz egal wer cool und der
kommentare können sich wieder
aufzuschütten